Bruce Arians joining us Continental Tire
Coaches Corner in the New Tampa Bay
Buccaneers head coach coach how are you
today good dad how you doing brother I'm
doing okay so how would you rate the
broadcasting industry there you had a
cameo there
give me the highs in the world the highs
are the producers directors and Greg
Gumbel and Trent green they were awesome
Melanie Collins the lows were traveling
man that was sorry but I wondered about
this that when you stopped coaching and
I've talked to a couple of coaches about
this that you you realize there's a
whole lot of downtime like you can
prepare for a football game but you're
so used to having your days you know
structured how hard was that adjustment
to go from being a head coach to just
being a broadcaster for a game you know
I was surprised at how much work goes
into calling a game you know you can
review your film on Mondays start
looking at the next opponents on Tuesday
Wednesday o Wednesday I played golf and
Thursday I tried to play I was leaving
town already to catch another flight to
where we were going I never unpacked my
bags the whole year first thing you did
when you got the job as head coach to
Tampa Bay was one oh gosh just sit down
and reflect for a second and be very
very thankful that I'm back in the
business
did you and there was the report Jay
Glazer had that you were asked to take a
physical before you were being offered
this job is that true yeah got a total
physical and I was really glad to do
because I had one in about a year free
and it was great okay but have you ever
been asked to do that before before you
got a job no no no never
how is your health it's fantastic I mean
my one doctor at the lake told me I
don't want your cholesterol any lower on
what that you're doing and but yeah I
mean it's fantastic what did you miss
most
you lose 35 what did you miss most about
being head coach
it's all relationships a locker room and
people that don't grow up in locker
rooms don't know what I'm probably
talking about but the Brotherhood of a
locker room in building a team and then
I missed the arena I was going to
practices as a broadcaster on Friday
actually almost stepped on the field and
tried to correct a guy one time as
innocent your team it sounds like you're
all in on Jameis Winston is that right
yeah yes indeed I've known you for a
long time and he's a very bright young
man he's a great work ethic and he's
obviously very very talented so you know
put a couple good really good coaches
around him and I feel extremely
fortunate to have a quarterback that
young and that good you bring it in
Byron Leftwich yeah and trying to get
him signed up here today and he'll be
our offensive coordinator and then Clyde
Christensen who I think is one of the
best quarterback coaches ever will coach
the quarterbacks is there a chance you
bring back the creamsicle uniforms oh
yeah for sure I'm just gonna ask what
color do you look good in you know you
pulled off the Arizona red bear so I
don't know if you is is creamsicle
slimming hey you know I think so
especially with if you match it with an
off-white that is really good what else
do you know about this team well we
played them just not too long ago and
obviously the wide receiver rooms loaded
up with really good players to the tight
end room is one of the best in the
league offensive line probably needs a
little improvement but there's there's
guys there we got a young back and you
know hard running back so I think
offensively it's really really in good
shape defensively very young secondary
and had some injuries fast rule F having
played these two linebackers or three
lamb burgers can really run and so yeah
I mean just I think we're going to need
some influx of young players on the
defensive side but I think roster wise
it's
were you up for the Cleveland Browns job
no never heard from Glee
okay any other teams no I I really I
told a couple team to know when they
first felt out I mean covers were
surprised us when came open and then
when you have ownership like this and
then the general manager is a good
friend who I've worked with I mean
everything kind of and then all my
assistants were available so because I
Stars just kind of a line for this thing
is I got more and more excited about it
but you didn't pick it because of
whether going from Arizona to Tampa to
be able to play more golf right didn't
hurt it's good to have you back in the
league their coach and good luck there
in Tampa thank you brother
alright that's Bruce Arians new head
coach bringing back the creamsicle yeah
you know you go from you go from
Scottsdale and you know you got to get
some warm weather they're taking over
yeah I think he had Jameis Winston at
his football camp when Jameis was in
high school I think that's when they
first crossed paths and sounds like he's
all-in on Jameis Winston yes McLovin why
did this sound to me like Bruce Arians
has a slight southern accent he's from I
think he went to Temple he's from
Pennsylvania I felt like he was almost
through it I feel like coach Ian's
turned him into a southern coaching is
that crazy well Chris Carter played in
Minnesota and Philadelphia's from Ohio
and if you hear Chris Carter he's got a
southern accent is it football I don't
know yeah Paul I think Bruce Arians is a
little bit like the actor Jeff Bridges
Jeff Bridges sounds like he's from
Tennessee and I think he's from Los
Angeles yeah he's kind of got that yeah
let's get it going this little riding
Randy Macho Man Savage I love that he
calls you brother to Bruce there yeah
brother Bruce Arians brought you by a
continental tire coaches corner no
matter what you drive where you drive
how you drive continental has a tire for
you continental tire dot-com for more
Dan Patrick show to the
it's channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]